the following content is provided under
a Creative Commons license your support
will help MIT OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational resources
for free
to make a donation or to view additional
materials from hundreds of MIT courses
visit MIT opencourseware at ocw.mit.edu
hi our topic today sounds a little bit
naughty at first glance it's called
improper integrals and rather than give
a long speech about why they're called
improper let me try and start our
lecture a little bit different from our
usual approach by giving you a little
bit of a mathematical calculus riddle
namely let me just say this we'll call
our lecture today improper integrals and
we'll start off by saying find the flaw
I would like to integrate DX over x
squared from minus 1 to 1 using the
first fundamental theorem of integral
calculus I say this is G of 1 minus G of
minus 1 where G prime is any function
whose derivative is 1 over x squared
well in particular do I know a function
whose derivative is 1 over x squared
well I guess minus 1 over X in other
words the derivative of X to the minus 1
is minus X to the minus 2 with a minus
in front that makes it plus X to the
minus 2 that's plus 1 over x squared in
any event I can then compute that G of 1
is minus 1 G of minus 1 is 1 therefore G
of 1 minus G of minus 1 is minus 1 minus
1 is minus 2 therefore the integral from
minus 1 to 1 DX over x squared is minus
2 and the question is find the flaw okay
find the flaw and since again we're on
limit of time let me if you haven't
already discovered the flaw at least
point out why you should be suspicious
of a flaw remember we visualize this as
an area under a curve in other words in
a way the base of our region is the
closed interval from minus 1 to 1 and
the height of our region at any point is
given by 1 over x squared well look at 1
over x squared
certainly 1 over x squared can't be
negative because for any real number X
its square is non-negative and 1 over a
non-negative number is certainly non
that
in particular then since my region never
goes below the x-axis I would expect
that the area represented by this should
be positive in other words this is the
sum of positive numbers taken in the
limit in other words the fact that the
integrand is non-negative tells me that
whatever the integral turns out to be it
must be at least as big as 0 and minus 2
does not fulfill that criteria in other
words something must be wrong here
because we get a negative answer in a
situation where a negative answer is
preposterous and the reason that I
wanted to pick this approach is I think
that the best way to motivate that
something is wrong is precisely by
winding up with a preposterous answer in
a situation where we know the answer is
preposterous
then we know we must be on our guard to
see what went wrong and what did go
wrong well the key point is this and
again it's something that we've said
many many times but I think it takes a
counter example before it really sinks
in people are always quoting the first
fundamental theorem in general this it's
easy to remember that the integral from
A to B f of X DX is G of B minus G of a
where G prime equals F but the thing
that we must be extremely careful of is
that this definition requires that F be
at least piecewise continuous on the
interval from A to B remember when we
took the limit and put the squeezed on
we required that there be continuity so
that we could pass to the limit the
important point is in this particular
example that we're dealing with observe
that 1 over x squared is infinite I
write this in quotation marks to point
out you have a 1 over 0 form which we
usually abbreviate infinity in other
words 1 over x squared increases without
bound as X approaches zero and notice
that zero was in within the limits of
our integration from minus 1 to 1 at any
rate without further ado this leads to a
fundamental definition which in terms of
today's lesson I call definition number
one and that is the integral from A to B
f of X DX is called improper and there
going to be two types of improper
integrals as we'll find out very shortly
but it's called improper of the first
kind
if and only if f is infinite for at
least one C in the interval from A to B
and again let me caution you about this
and I'll summarize at the end of the
lecture again to remind you if you look
at this particular integral it doesn't
look at all suspicious in fact that's
where the trap came in in this problem
over here the reason that we wound up
with minus two is that we just
integrated 1 over x squared forgetting
that there was a point at which the
integrand was infinite in the given
interval ok and so the question that
comes up is how shall we handle this if
we have an infinity in here and the
answer is let's work around the point at
which the integral or the integrand is
infinite let's see what that means and
this again is a continuation of the
definition I guess if C is the only
point in the closed interval from A to B
at which F is infinite we define the
integral from A to B f of X DX to be the
following limit it's the limit as H
approaches 0 through positive values the
definite integral from A to C minus H in
other words you're stopping somewheres
before you get to this bad point
evaluating f of X DX and there's no harm
done in here because you see f of X is
infinite only at X equal C in this
problem consequently if you stop prior
to C f of X is at least piecewise
continuous every place in here then you
jump over the bad point pick up again at
C plus h and say plus the integral from
C plus h to be f of X DX this limit as H
approaches 0 through positive values now
again this may sound very abstract so to
give this a more realistic meaning to
you let's interpret this again in terms
of an area what we're saying is this
pictorially we have a function which is
piecewise continuous at least on the
entire interval from A to B except at
the Point C where we have an infinite
discontinuity an infinite jump what we
do is is we pick a positive number H and
mock off the intervals C - H - C + H
surrounding C we then compute the area
we then compute the area of this shaded
region that's exactly what's inside the
brackets over here you see notice that
this sum is what it's the sum of two
integrals one of which names this area
and the other of which names this area
and what we say is let's put the squeeze
on and see what limiting value this area
approaches as we squeeze all the space
out around C in other words what's
really happening over here what we're
really saying is why can't we treat an
infinite region the same as if it were a
finite region taking the limit as the
size of the strip in here goes to zero
and here's the key point you see as H
approaches C from both sides notice that
the width of this region approaches zero
by the same token the height of the
region is imprisoning infinity in
essence what we're running into again is
that the problem of determining the area
of an infinite region involves the study
of infinity x 0 in fact the question
sort of is does H go to 0 faster than F
of C plus or minus H goes to infinity in
fact I think that's an important enough
observation so I've written it down here
to make sure that you notice it the
question sent us about the question the
problem of whether H approaches 0 faster
than whatever this means faster than F
of C plus a minus H approaches infinity
in our particular example this didn't
happen now again if you're afraid of the
symbol infinity let's deal with the
finite case and take the limit later in
other words instead of looking at the
integral from 0 to 1 DX over x squared
let's look at the integral from H to 1
integral from H to 1 DX over x squared
and then later we'll take the limit as H
approaches 0 in particular if this is my
region R namely bounded above by the
curve y equals 1 over x squared below by
the x-axis on the left by the line x
equals H and on the right by the line x
equals 1
the area of the region R is written what
integral H to 1 DX over x squared notice
that as long as H is not 0 our integrand
is continuous therefore we can use the
first fundamental theorem to evaluate it
it's the integral it's what it's minus 1
over X evaluated between H and 1 putting
in the upper limit gives me a minus 1
putting in the lower limit gives me
minus one over H but I'm subtracting
that so it becomes plus 1 over H in
other words the area of my region R is 1
over H minus 1 notice then that as ace
that a sub R as H approaches 0 from the
right becomes the limit of one over H as
H approaches 0 from the right minus 1
and the limit of one over H as H
approaches 0 from the right it's clearly
infinity in other words as H gets
arbitrarily close to 0 through positive
values 1 over H increases without any
bound in other words as what this means
in plain English is that we can make the
area of the region R as arbitrarily
large as we wish just by choosing H to
be sufficiently close to zero here you
see in other words as H approaches 0
what's happening here is that this curve
is not approaching the y-axis fast
enough to allow us to get a finite area
and by the way let me make one little
aside comparing this with our previous
answer you may recall and let me just
pull this board down here to remind you
of that you may recall then when we
worked this problem before we got the
wrong answer negative tool okay now look
at in terms of my problem over here
I took we went from minus 1 to 1 so this
is only half of the region that we're
talking about notice that the minus 2
comes from this C twice minus 1 by
symmetry the interesting thing is notice
here that when you take the limit well
forgetting that there's an infinite
discontinuity here when you let H
approach 0 you tend to say let's forget
about the function of H in here notice
here is H approach 0 this thing went to
infinity by ignoring it that's where you
got the answer - 2 though it was by
assuming that as H got small the
function of age got small we threw out
an infinite part of our answer though as
this was the thing that we have to worry
about in this particular case we slurred
over something that wasn't going to zero
fast enough by the way let me caution
you and point out that in this
particular example it happened that we
that infinity times zero became infinite
it is possible however that we can
approach that as H approaches zero it
may happen that H approaches zero fast
enough so that we do get a finite area
to show you this let's just change the
problem slightly instead of taking y
equals one over x squared
let's take y equals one over the square
root of x the same problem and by the
way here's the subtlety of this again if
you were to sketch y equals 1 over the
square root of x alongside of y equals 1
over x squared
in fact fast enough so that even though
we get an infinite region it has only a
finite area in particular here's what
I'm saying now let R be the region
bounded above by y equals 1 over the
square root of X below by the x-axis on
the left by x equals H and on the right
by x equals 1 again since the only place
that 1 over the square root of x has an
infinite discontinuity is when x is 0
and since H is greater than 0 here we
have a continuous integrand the area of
the region R therefore is given by what
any function whose derivative is 1 over
the square root of x evaluated between H
and 1 again
sparing you the details of that if you
differentiate twice X to the 1/2 the one
half and the two cancel and you get 1
over the square root of x in other words
2 square roots of X is a function whose
derivative is 1 over the square root of
x if I now evaluate that between 1 and H
I get 2 minus 2 square roots of H if I
now take the limit of a sub R as H
approaches 0 notice that what happens
here is that as H approaches 0 so as the
square root of H and the area turns out
to be 2 in the limit in other words the
area of the region R in this particular
case is also a function of H but the pot
that depends on H
goes to zero as H goes to zero in fact
notice in this particular case and why I
couldn't have started with this example
is that if I took this example and you
did it the incorrect way in other words
if you fail to notice that 1 over the
square root of x was discontinuous at x
equals 0 and you just did this problem
mechanically you see and evaluate this
between 0 & 1 you would have got the
right answer and the reason that you
will get the right answer
is that in the limit process notice here
that the part of the answer that depends
on H does actually go to 0 in the limit
at any rate using all of this as
motivation we come to a new piece of
terminology that we should define namely
if f is infinite at x equals C where C
is someplace in the interval from A to B
then the improper integral A to B f of X
DX is called convergent if the
particular limit that we talked about
previously in the definition of how you
compute integral from A to B f of X DX
if that particular limit exists meaning
it's a finite number then we call the
integral a convergent improper integral
on the other hand meaning what if this
limit doesn't exist if for example the
limit is infinite then we call the
integral divergent in other words in our
first example the integral was divergent
in the second example the integral was
convergent by the way it's rather
interesting to point out two I shouldn't
say it's rather interesting it's just my
exclusive I don't know if any other way
of motivating improper integrals of the
second kind but the thing that's worth
observing is this that when we when we
evaluated the area under the curve here
from 0 to 1 we elected to pick strips
like this remember this is why we got is
that infinite discontinuity we picked
our strip's to look like this the
question that comes up is why couldn't
we have picked our strip's to be
horizontal in other words if we had in
terms of say inverse functions in route
at the role of x and y why couldn't we
have computed our area by picking strips
like this
adding them all up from 1 to B and then
taking the limit as B went to infinity
in other words if I wanted to compute
the area of this region using horizontal
strips I would have had what I would
have had the area of the region R is the
integral from 1 to B and remember if y
equals 1 over x squared X is 1 over the
square root of Y therefore the area of
the region R is integral from 1 to be
square dy over the square root of y
notice that the square root of y is
certainly continuous in 1 over the
square root of y is continuous in this
interval at any rate I could then have
evaluated this integrand here and taken
the limit as B approaches infinity and
by the way the abbreviation for writing
the limit of the integral 1 to B as B
approaches infinity is to simply write
integral from 1 to infinity dy over the
square root of Y and this is all this
thing means for example in this
particular case notice that as B goes to
infinity so does the square root of B
therefore 2 square roots of B minus 2
goes to infinity as B approaches
infinity and we find by a second method
that the area of our region is infinite
and again we have another kind of
improper integral but structurally this
improper integral is completely
different from the improper integral
that we had before namely
before we had an improper integral where
the integrand became infinite even
though the limits of integration stayed
finite notice what happens in this case
in this particular case notice that the
integrand stays finite it's the limits
of integration that become infinite in
other words this leads to our next
definition of a new type of improper
integral namely the integral say from a
to infinity f of X DX where by this we
mean the abbreviation limit as B
approaches infinity integral from A to B
f of X DX where f is continuous in this
entire range in other words for X
greater than or equal to a that type of
an integral is called an improper
integral of the second kind in other
words in the first kind the integrand
becomes
infinite but the limits of integration
are finite in the second kind the
integrand stays finite but the limits of
integration take on an infinite range
and the important point is that these
two are very closely connected in other
words in terms of the example that I
just showed you I wanted you to see how
you can get from an integral of the
first kind to an improper integral of a
second kind
just by replacing your vertical strips
by horizontal strips in fact in terms of
my first example over here notice that
indeed 1 over x squared and 1 over the
square root of x where X is at least as
big as 0 are inverses by the way the
reason I say X is it well in fact bigger
than 0 otherwise I have a 0 denominator
here the reason I point this out is that
if we don't presuppose that X is
positive remember the square root
function or the squaring function is not
one-to-one
so I have to be very careful when I talk
about inverse functions the thing I want
you to see however is the graph of y
equals 1 over x squared is the inverse
of the graph y equals 1 over the square
root of x in other words essentially by
interchanging the role of the x and y
axes you go from one graph to the other
you see in particular the integral 1 to
infinity DX over x squared namely
finding the area of this particular
region is the inverse of finding the
area of this particular region in other
words notice that y equals 1 over x
squared behaves for large values of X
the same as y equals 1 over the square
root of x behaves for small positive
values of x again let me point out that
much of this will be done much more
hardcore in our learning exercises and
in the reading material and the like and
so I pass over some of this in a fairly
quick way but what I want to make sure
it's clear before we begin the exercises
and the reading material is that we have
a good idea as to what improper
integrals mean at any rate continuing on
this way what do I mean by the integral
from 1 to infinity DX over x squared
well it's an improper integral of a
second type because the integrand is
finite between 1 and infinity the limits
of integration span an infinite space
over here
anyway that's what the limit as B
approaches infinity integral from 1 to B
DX over x squared DX over x squared at
any rate what is the integral of 1 over
x squared it's minus 1 over X if I
evaluate that that's minus 1 over B plus
1 and if I now take the limit as B
approaches infinity that answer is 1 in
other words what this means pictorially
is is the following if I look at the
area of this region R for any value of B
whatsoever that area is equal to 1 minus
1 over B in other words no matter how
big B becomes the area of this region R
can never be as big as 1 unit and in the
limit as B goes out as far as we wish
what we're really saying is what that
the area of this region R can be made
arbitrarily close to 1 just by choosing
B to be arbitrarily large and by the way
this you see leads to an interesting
observation namely at this end of the
spectrum the curve was not approaching
the y-axis fast enough to make this
integral finite remember the integral
from 0 to 1 DX over x squared was
infinite however for large values of X
the curve does approach the x axis fast
enough so that not only is the enclosed
area finite it can't even be bigger than
1 and I thought that might be an
interesting example for you to think
about for a while another type of
interesting example worth thinking about
for a while is the second example let's
take the region R to be bounded above by
y equals 1 over X on the left by x
equals 1 on the right by x equals B and
below by the x-axis and let's compute
the area of the region R again the area
of the region R is the definite integral
from 1 to B DX over X and that's equal
to the natural log of B namely the in
this integral is logged absolute value
of x log absolute value of B is just log
B log 1 is 0 so the area of the region R
is log B and since as B increases
without bound it's log increases without
bound we find that the area of the
region R is infinite
in fact another way of saying this is
what this is the integral 1 to infinity
DX over X and this is therefore what a
divergent improper integral of the
second type alright so far so good at
any rate let me review our volumes of
revolution rotation let's take the
region R and rotate it about the x axis
if we rotate our about the x axis
remember a volume of revolution is just
PI Y squared DX from 1 to B well my Y is
1 over X that's 1 over x squared then
the integral of 1 over x squared is
minus 1 over X notice then as before the
volume when I rotate our about the x
axis is just pi times 1 minus 1 over B
in other words what this says is as B
gets very very large sodas are yet if I
rotate R about the x axis no matter how
big B is the volume is just P times pi
times 1 minus 1 over B and as X as B
approaches infinity this goes to 0 and
my volume is just PI in other words this
area gets infinitely large yet the
volume generated by rotating that area
remains finite again another
idiosyncrasy of working with improper
integrals and infinite regions you're
going to be very very careful about how
rapidly something approaches zero or
infinity because infinity times zero is
indeterminate in other words here is a
very important observation an infinite
area can enclose or can generate a
finite volume be very very careful in
dealing with improper integrals and by
the way let me make one computational
aside in trying to determine whether a
particular improper integral is
convergent or not we do not have to be
able to compute the limit itself I
mentioned this because it's very
important sometime you'll be given an
integral which you don't know how to
integrate directly at
for example it usually comes up integral
e to the minus x squared DX say between
minus between 1 and 30 and you want to
know where this converges about you
don't care what the limit is because
once you know it converges you can
approximate it to as great a degree of
accuracy as you wish so the question is
does this converge or doesn't it and
again the answer is let's see what
happens on this particular range for
example in those we know for example
that if X is greater greater than or
equal to 1 for numbers in magnitude at
least as big as 1 the square exceeds the
number okay
in particular by the way if x squared
exceeds X minus x squared cannot exceed
minus X in other words on this
particular interval that we're dealing
with say from 1 to B as B approaches
infinity e to the minus x squared is
less than minus X okay therefore e to
the might because the exponential
function is one-to-one e to the minus x
squared DX from 1 to B cannot exceed the
integral from 1 to B e to the minus X DX
in other words since this exponent is
less than this exponent this integral is
less than this one however it turns out
that we know how to evaluate this one
how do you integrate e to the minus X
it's just minus e to the minus X and if
we evaluate that between 1 and B we find
that we get 1 over e minus 1 over e to
the B power B is some positive number
this thing here is less than infinity in
fact as B approaches infinity this
approaches 0 and the limiting value is 1
over e in other words what we now know
is is that whatever this improper
integral is it cannot exceed 1 over e
even though we don't know what the exact
answer is pictorially you see what
happens over here is that the curve
which I've drawn in the accentuated
chalk this curve is y equals e to the
minus x squared the light curve is y
equals e to the minus x notice that
these two curves crisscross when x
equals 1 and all we're saying is that
since the white curve chops off a finite
area and the accentuated curve the Dok
curve is inside the white one
certainly the area enclosed by the black
curve could not exceed that of the white
curve in other words if this region here
approaches a finite value as X goes to
infinity so much the other region and
this is essentially the theory behind
improper integrals enclosing there is
one thing I would like to say about this
it's a short summary but his dhole idea
it may be difficult to evaluate improper
integrals of a second kind but in a
certain manner of speaking they're not
dangerous in one in what manner of
speaking well when you see the limits on
the side integral sign like 8 to
infinity or minus infinity to be or
minus infinity to infinity you're on the
lookout you're on the lookout to be
careful about something going wrong
there's something about the symbol
infinity which hopefully strikes a
certain fear or respect in your minds
when you work mathematically see we have
a warning to beware in this case however
the dangerous part is that when you're
given an improper integral of the first
type and I don't know the best way of
saying this other than to say perhaps
that mathematics has no built-in burglar
alarms what I mean by that is if you're
supposed to multiply five and three to
get the right answer to a problem and
instead you add five and three you're
going to get eight for the answer even
though it's incorrect there's not going
to be a bustah that goes off and says
please do not add these two numbers in
other words if you go ahead over here
and you forget that f of X may be
infinite and you go ahead and integrate
this using the first fundamental theorem
you're going to get an answer just like
we did in our beginning lecture exercise
at the beginning of the lecture which
happened to be the wrong answer so in
other words the word of warning here is
whenever you see an integral with finite
limits of integration check the
integrand and make sure it doesn't blow
up it doesn't become infinite at any
rate with these words we finish our
block on integration and until next time
goodbye
funding for the publication of this
video was provided by the Gabriella and
Paul Rosenbaum foundation
help ocw continue to provide free and
open access to MIT courses by making a
donation at ocw.mit.edu/donate